[Musik]
Menschenhandel findet statt in der
Schweiz hat Frauen die sind nicht
freiwillig da die werden gezwungen die
werden ausbütend und die
ist mittlerweile für wenig Geld zu haben
die Prostituierten kommen fast alle aus
Nigeria oder Osteuropa
[Musik]
ich war eine Weile in Italien dann hat
mich jemand in die Schweiz gebracht und
mich an seine Kontakte weitergegeben
verlassen
Menschen aus Afrika breiten sich seit
Jahren in der Schweiz und ganz Europa
aus
mehr als drei Viertel der Prostituierten
machen ihren Job nicht freiwillig
[Musik]
Platz Zürich
die Methoden im Business werden immer
brutaler
du kannst nicht weglaufen du kannst dich
nicht verstecken die kriegen dich
nigerianische Netzwerke verdienen
Milliarden mit der Zwangsprostitution in
Europa
das ist klar frei weil die Opfer von
Menschenhandel von Nigeria bis sie in
Europa sind ausbüttet werden
die Spuren der Menschenhändler führen
von der Landstraße zu den drahtziehen im
Ausland
jedes Jahr Schleusen sie tausende Frauen
nach Europa ein um die Nachfrage nach
billigem Sex zu bedienen
ich bin ein Mensch ich habe Angst
[Musik]
die A3 auf der Höhe der Raststätte Mumpf
im Kanton Aargau
hier ist eine Frau im vergangenen Winter
vor Menschenhändlern geflüchtet
die 32-jährige Frau kommt aus Westafrika
festhalten
ist die Frau ist eine von wenigen die
die Flucht vor den Menschenhändlern
gewagt hat die Dunkelziffer schätzt wann
ist hoch
polizeiliche Ermittlungen haben bisher
nichts ergeben die Frau konnte keine
genaueren Angaben machen
Peter Becher ist Chef der
ermittlungsabteilung
strukturkriminalität bei der
Kantonspolizei Zürich und weiß wie
schwierig Ermittlungen in diesen Fällen
sind
Afrikanerinnen
mit einer Frau konfrontiert sind die
Merkmale erkennen
und dann richtig handelt und die Frau
dann in einer opferhilfestelle oder eine
geeignet
im konkreten Fall hat die Polizei sofort
reagiert und die Frau in den
Schutzräumen des Frauen
Informationszentrums untergebracht
das Fitz bietet MigrantInnen die von
Gewalt und Ausbeutung betroffen sind
Hilfe an
fit betreut und begleitet und beratet um
400 Betroffene von Menschenhandel
Nigeria
sind zum Beispiel sehr sehr ähnliche
Geschichte erzählen wie die betroffen
bisher gab es allerdings keine
Verurteilungen
obwohl die Polizei weiß dass die
Menschenhändler in der Schweiz sehr
aktiv sind
Gott im Bereich von
Opfer extrem volatil sind also wir
machen Kontrolle
die sind nicht ortsgebunden und reagiert
sehr schnell auf Druck also da haben wir
sehr gut vernetzt national und
internationalen
der ehemalige Journalist Stefan Fuchs
recherchiert seit Jahren die
Hintergründe von westafrikanischen
Menschenhändlern und arbeitet eng mit
der Polizei zusammen
die Taverne Hand die nigerianische
Kriminalität aus 50 nach 4 Organisation
definiert in der Schweiz sich mit
anderen Schritt zurück mich hat das noch
nie gesehen eine klassifizieren
etwa ein Fünftel der Männer in der
Schweiz nehmen regelmäßig sexuelle
Dienstleistungen in Anspruch und lassen
sich das nach Schätzungen jährlich
gesamthaft etwa 3,5 Milliarden Franken
kosten
Sex mit Zwangsprostituierten ist das
strafbar doch verstöße können kaum
verfolgt werden
drängten
Zwangs Prostituierte Kontakten auf der
anderen Seite ist es so dass
die ausdrückliche Rechtsgrundlage fällt
um eine Nordeuropa zum Beispiel Hand wo
freie wirklich zu erreichen
Frieden setzt die Polizei verdeckte
Ermittlerinnen als Prostituierte ein um
freier zu überführen
in Zürich schätzt man prostituieren sich
rund 1500 Frauen täglich etwa 80 bis 150
kommen aus Nigeria
seit 25 Jahren betreibt Cornelia Zöhrer
in der Nähe der Langstraße ein Nachtcafé
der Heilsarmee wo sich die Frauen
treffen können
Zwangsprostitution aus Nigeria ist für
sie nichts neues das sehe ich ungefähr
12 13 Jahre her das sind zum ersten Mal
zu Osis nach Kaffee kochen es ist sehr
schwierig sie am Anfang
will sie eigentlich gar nicht
persönliches Zeiten bei allem was
irgendwo mir die Situation gegangen ist
wie sie da wohnen wo sie herkommen sind
gerade abblockt so sind sehr herzlich
sehr zugewandt aber da ist niedrig
gefunden dass viele von
italienischen Spanisch
[Musik]
es ist nach wie vor schwierig an die
Frauen heranzukommen sie werden in ganz
Europa herumgeschoben Deutschland kämpft
mit dem gleichen Problem
ZDF-Journalist Jan-Philipp Scholz
recherchiert im Internet und kommt so
auf die Spur einer jungen Nigerianerin
sie lebt in Süddeutschland und hat in
verschiedenen europäischen Ländern als
Prostituierte gearbeitet jetzt will sie
aussteigen
seitdem ist ihr Leben in Gefahr sagt sie
lange zögert sie schließlich ist sie
aber doch bereit sich mit Jan Philipp zu
treffen
Blessing ist nicht ihr richtiger Name
das ist das erste Mal dass ich jemandem
meine Geschichte erzähle seitdem das
alles passiert ist habe ich wirklich
Angst riesige Angst
ich bekomme viele Anrufe von deutschen
Nummern von italienischen Nummern sogar
französische Nummern rufen mich an
ich halte viele Drohungen
in Europa etwas erzähle werde ich
sterben
ich habe niemanden mit dem ich reden
kann
wenn meine Eltern aus Afrika anrufen vor
allem meine Mutter kann ich Ihnen nicht
davon erzählen was ich hier durchmache
all die Dinge die ich erlebe
hier
das ist hart das macht mich kaputt
[Musik]
Blessing ist bei bekannten untergekommen
und versucht alle Kontakte ins Milieu
abzubrechen
die Vergangenheit lässt sie trotzdem
nicht los
[Musik]
es war schrecklich um 9 Uhr Abends
mussten wir aus dem Haus den Bus nehmen
zur Arbeit fahren
manchmal hatte ich vielleicht vier
manchmal fünf Männer manchmal sogar mehr
manchmal auch nur zwei
perfekt
die ganze Zeit war mir klar dass dies
nicht das Leben ist dass ich mir erhofft
hatte
aber ich hatte keine Wahl ich musste es
tun
ich habe einen Schwur geleistet sie
haben meine Schamhaare meine Unterhose
meine Fingernägel und mein Blut mein
Finger News Blut von meiner Zunge
alle diese Dinge können Sie gegen mich
verwenden der Voodoo Priester hat die
komplette Macht über mich
[Musik]
martialische
Methode der Menschenhändler um junge
Frauen aus Westafrika gefügig zu machen
in einer Angst einflößenden Zeremonie
wird den Opfern klargemacht dass sie die
Forderungen der Menschenhändler befolgen
müssen ihnen wird gedroht dass ihnen und
Ihren Familien etwas Schlimmes passiert
sollten Sie sich nicht an die Abmachung
halten
ich bin ein Mensch ich habe Angst
aus ihrem Heimatland sehr viel von
deiner Frau sind auch sehr gläubig und
das passt in das Konzept vom vom Glauben
her
und mit
dem Schwur hat man sie zum Teil sehr im
Griff und löste
Jan Philipp Scholz Recherchen führen in
die bayerische Provinz Blessing hat in
die drobotschaften weitergeschickt
ein ehemaliges Mitglied an eine
koreanischen anti-menschen Handels
Taskforce
nach massiven Drohungen im Heimatland
ist der Mann nach Deutschland geflüchtet
und hat hier Asyl beantragt
[Musik]
kannst du dir die Nachricht anhören und
mir übersetzen was sie sagt
das ist eine Madame die über eines ihrer
Mädchen spricht
das hört sich so an als ob das Mädchen
nicht mehr zahlen will
sie sagt ich werde den Boys Bescheid
geben dass sie sich um sie kümmern
die Jungs haben bereits ihr Foto sie
werden sie kriegen sie wird nicht
entkommen
der Informant erklärt
wenigerianische Menschenhändler
normalerweise vorgehen
also das Leben des Mädchens hängt
komplett von der Madame
die Boys werden alles mit dir machen was
die Madame sagt ist das
in Nigeria werden die jungen Frauen von
einer sogenannten Madame eine Art
weiblichen Zuhälterin und ihren
Komplizen mit falschen Versprechungen
angelockt einen Teil der Kosten für die
Schlepper legt die Madame aus und
fordert später ein Vielfaches zurück
durch einen judo-priester werden die
Frauen zusätzlich eingeschüchtert in
Europa übt ein komplexes Mafia ähnliches
netzwerkkontrolle über die Frauen aus
sogenannte Boys machen die Opfer gefügig
oft auch mit Hilfe von Gewalt und
treiben das Geld ein
aussteigerinnen können den Netzwerken
kaum entkommen da auch ihre Familien in
der Heimat unter Druck gesetzt werden
in Zürich hat Stefan Fuchs über Facebook
den Menschenhändler Jeffrey ausfindig
gemacht
dieser war sofort bereit eine Reise für
zwei fiktive Frauen von Nigeria aus zu
organisieren
D
das Spiel so lange können
Transaktion
identifizieren und Bankkonten
identifizieren es geht natürlich
verschiedene Fluchtwagen
noch Europa von Nigeria wusste typische
ganz
große Stadt wo man auch sogenannte
connection-
[Musik]
Zwischenhalt für die meisten sind
connection Häuser in Scheba ist
connection House ist es sicheres Haus wo
die Frauen nachahmet was sie schaffen
was sie ihre Prostitution die in Libyen
wieder braucht werden das war innerhalb
von wenigen Wochen sie aber mehrere
Monate bis sie einfach das
reisegearbeitet
sie werden zum Teil zu Tode geprügelt
sie werden vergewaltigt aber auch in
Europa haben
Videoaufnahmen es gibt gebildet wo seine
Ruth als er merkt dass etwas nicht
stimmt
ist nur ein Zwischenhalt
und da wartet man bis die Boots parat
sind nach Italien und da werden sie sich
bereits erste Mal in Europa den
prostituieren wichtige Ausgangspunkt
Italien Norditalien generell aber auch
auf Frankreich was sie in ganz Europa
verschoben werden
[Musik]
ich denke sie sind unter Kontrolle
allgemein
ist eine der wenigen die redet die
Nigerianerin war selbst
Zwangsprostituierte in Zürich jetzt
arbeitet sie mit der Polizei zusammen
ich bin mit dem Flüchtlingsboot nach
Europa gekommen sie haben uns gerettet
und an Land gebracht
dann hat mich jemand in die Schweiz
gebracht und mich an seine Kontakte
weitergegeben das war's von da an habe
ich auf der Straße gearbeitet
mit Hilfe einer opferorganisation
schaffte Julia den Absprung nun will sie
Stefan Fuchs zeigen wie die Frauen hier
leben
mein Boss hat nicht in der Schweiz
gelebt einige von denen haben Angst vor
Europa aber sie haben immer jemanden der
dich beobachtet und das Geld eintreibt
Julia wird mit einem versteckten
Aufnahmegerät ausgestattet um die Aktion
mit Stefan Fuchs zusammen verdeckt zu
filmen
aber es ist wichtig dass die Welt sieht
in welchen Verhältnissen diese Frauen
Leben vielleicht kann ich sie dazu
bringen sich mehr anzuvertrauen sie
haben immer Angst vor der Polizei aber
bei einer Afrikanerin werden Sie
sicherlich keine Bedenken haben
Julia macht sich auf den Weg an die
Landstraße
eine nigerianische Prostituierte erklärt
sich bereit sie zu einem Hotel zu führen
indem sie mit anderen afrikanischen
Frauen ein Zimmer teilen muss
[Musik]
die Zustände sind schockierend
auf vier Etagen Hausen hier mehr als 40
Prostituierte an den Wänden schimmelt es
es stinkt nach Fäkalien
und das mitten in Zürich wenige
Kilometer von der noblen Bahnhofstraße
entfernt
wir machen das weil wir keine andere
Möglichkeit haben um Geld zu verdienen
ich brauche Geld
was ist denn passiert
meine Madame hat mich geschlagen
wenig später müssen sie den Dreh
abbrechen sie werden gewarnt das
Aufpasser über ihre Anwesenheit
informiert wurden
[Musik]
am nächsten Tag wird Stefan Fuchs die
Bilder mit Julia aus
trotz des abrupten Abbruchs bringt die
Aktion neue Erkenntnisse
ein Trend den die beiden erkennen die
Frauen werden immer jünger
die schockieren das ist schockierend
diese zwei von den Frauen gestern
wirkten ganz zart die tat mir besonders
leid als ich sie gesehen habe
wie zerbrechlich sie wirken
offenbar müssen auch Mädchen unter 18
anschaffen
ja klar sie bringen auch Minderjährige
das größte Problem sei dass die Opfer
ein falsches Bild von Europa hätten
findet Julia
okay ich glaube in Nigeria wissen viele
nicht dass die Menschen hier ein solches
Leben führen müssen sie können sich das
nicht vorstellen so viele Leute auf
engem Raum es ist wie ein Sklaven leben
und es gibt viele Menschen in ganz
Europa die so leben
in Frankreich in Deutschland in der
Schweiz in Italien
[Musik]
gegen die Zustände in den Zimmern an der
Landstraße können die Behörden nichts
tun und mehr Razzien wie zum Teil
politisch gefordert wird bringen selbst
aus der Sicht der Polizei nichts
vom Bereich sexuellen
damit wären auch mögliche Zeuginnen weg
und die Chance noch kleiner an die
Hintermänner heranzukommen
in dieser Frage sind sich die Polizei
und das Fitz einig
gerade auf dem Platz Zürich
spezialisiert die Polizei auf kantonaler
Ebene
Aufklärung
es wird wirklich gemacht
[Musik]
obwohl die Polizei den Fokus vor allem
auch auf die Hintermänner legt sind die
Frauen nicht bereit auszusagen
schon seit 25 Jahren
noch nie hat sie erlebt dass eine gegen
ihre Peiniger ausgesagt hätte
sie handorscht vor allem wenn es nur am
abzahlen sind ist das extrem schwierig
wir haben letzte eine K wo die ist
erstmals
entschieden und ich dachte Punkt ist
wirklich sie einerseits bin ich da
sicher sicher Frage
und ich komme ja wahrscheinlich eh
keinen Status übertragen die Perspektive
können wir Ihnen aktuell mit dem Ganzen
migrationsregimus eigentlich geht nicht
bitte die Personen aus Drittstaaten und
Nigeria können nicht legal nach Europa
migrieren sie können an dem Fall auch
nicht legal in Europa schaffen das heißt
sie sind eigentlich
illegalisiert die Weg ermöglichen und
das bringt sie ihnen Schuld wo sie nach
einem ausbildbar macht
die meisten nigerianischen Frauen sind
mit touristenvisas da doch es Pflichten
auch immer mehr Opfer von Menschenhandel
aus umliegenden Ländern in die Schweiz
sie stellen hier ein asylsuche obwohl
sie nicht auf Hilfe hoffen können
das ist aktuell so dass man Lücken im
Opfer hilft Gesetz Hand Personen wo im
Ostland betroffen von Menschenhandel
sind die werden in der Schweiz aufgrund
von
Opfer hilft Gesetz aktuell nicht
geschützt obwohl das die europäische
Konvention eigentlich vorsieht dass er
mir Handtuch wirklich ein Lücke im
Gesetz und die Zimmer aktuell
mit andere Akteurinnen
ein Vorstoß das
opferhilfegesetz auf Opfer aus dem
Ausland die hier einen Asylantrag
stellen auszudehnen ist im Parlament
hängig
doch Stefan Fuchs bezweifelt dass er
mehrheitsfähig ist
ich persönlich befürchte dass es ähm
Opfer Tourismus auslöst dass man das
missbraucht
vor dem her bin ich relativ kritisch
Frauen wichtig wenn man die Opfer
gesetzt wurde Schweiz vorher schon
richtig und konsequent umsetzt
politisch dürfte es tatsächlich
schwierig sein dass opferhilfegesetz
auch auf die im Ausland von
Menschenhandel betroffenen Frauen in der
Schweiz anzuwenden
die sozialdirektoren der Kantone
schlagen nun einen Kompromiss vor
mir sehr gedacht einfaches Buch der
pragmatische Lösung und im Vordergrund
stand nicht Entschädigung oder knurrik
sondern
Bewältigung von dem was sie erlaubt
haben für das haben wir eigentlich
vorgeschlagen
das Kompetenzzentrum
abklären gemacht und nachher lügen dass
die Opfer der zugegangen
nämlich zu der spezifische Beratung
betroffen
und auch zu Schutz Unterkünfte wenn Sie
das Buchen und im Moment haben alles
kein rechtliche Grundlage das heißt das
ist nicht sollte im Moment
es geht jedoch nicht nur um Opferschutz
sondern vor allem auch darum die
Hintermänner der afrikanischen Netzwerke
zu kriegen
um das zu erreichen hat die Polizei die
Ermittlungen interkantonal und national
intensiviert
Polizei
sind dass man schnell und auch
international vernetzt wesentlich ein
Schritt für Schritt
auch mit Stefan Fuß ist die Polizei
regelmäßig in Kontakt er hat
verschiedene Puzzlestücke zusammengefügt
um zu verstehen was das System der
Ausbeutung aufrechterhält
oft sind sogenannte Geheimbünde
involviert
die Netzwerke sind sehr straforganisiert
das heißt es geht
quasi und es geht verschiedene
Positionen vor
Wirtschaftsabteilung bis zur
Informationsabteilung es geht darum
sogenannten gemacht werden Mitgliedern
diese nigerianischen Geheimbünde Stellen
Europas Sicherheitsbehörden schon länger
vor große Probleme
bereits 2019 warnte auch der
Bundesnachrichtendienst vor den Gruppen
über Spanien und Italien würden sie
immer weiter nach West und zentral
Europa drängen
damals standen vor allem zwei Kulte im
Fokus die black-axx zu deutsch schwarze
Axt und die Supreme i confreternity
inzwischen kamen weitere Namen hinzu
unter ihnen die Vikings die Mehrheit und
die jurists
sie alle haben in den letzten Jahren in
zahlreichen europäischen Ländern ihren
Netzwerke aufgebaut
bei der Bundespolizei verfolgt man ihre
Strukturen und Machenschaften schon seit
20 Jahren
diese Bruderschaften sind in den 1960er
Jahren als Studentenverbindungen in
Nigeria entstanden in den 70er Jahren
wurden sie von der Regierung verboten da
sind sie in den Untergrund gegangen und
haben begonnen kriminelle Aktivitäten zu
entfalten um sich weiter zu entwickeln
und zu überleben
sie wurden aktiv in Menschenhandel und
in der Prostitution und sind in den
Drogenhandel eingestiegen in Europa und
der ganzen Welt und sichern sich so ihr
weiter bestehen
die Bruderschaften kontrollieren die
Frauen oft auf der gesamten Route vom
Transport durch Afrika über die
Flüchtlingsboote auf der Mittelmeer bis
hin zum Zielort in Europa
[Musik]
auch nach vielen Jahren Beschäftigung
mit dem Thema ist für Stefan Fuchs
verblüffend wie viel Geld mit dem Leiter
Frauen in der Schweiz verdient wird
[Musik]
auf der Landstraße in Zürich rund 150
40 Franken pro Job das geht täglich
hat die 6,5 Millionen Franken
umgesetzt werden
nur einen kleinen Teil dürfen die Frauen
behalten der Rest wird durch ein
illegales System nach Nigeria verschoben
die Bruderschaften sind über die Grenzen
vernetzt besonders das sogenannte
havala-system machen sie sich zu Nutze
das
urlaubssystem zur Gaube wie sie
funktioniert eigentlich wie Western
Union sie konnten zu einer
Vertrauensperson sie übergeht er das
Geld
Empfänger in Nigeria bekannt und der
galtempfänger Gott auch in der Latte
zeigt der Code und konnte aufgrund von
dem das Geld
gleichen ihre Schulden durch
gegenseitige Transfers oder dem
Schmuggel mit Schmuck Gold oder
Luxusautos immer wieder aus
was den Menschenhändlern beim Waschen
ihres schmutzigen Geldes hilft in den
meisten Ländern Europas kann man immer
noch vieles mit Cash bezahlen Autos
werden hier gekauft und die Nigeria mit
Gewinn wieder verkauft so wäscht sich
das Geld
zurück in Deutschland
auch Blessing musste ihre gesamten
Einkünfte an einen Geldeintreiber
abgeben
einen festen Preis gibt es nicht man
muss einfach Geld anschaffen selbst wenn
jemand nur 10 Euro für Sex zahlen will
lässt du dich manchmal darauf ein nur um
Geld präsentieren zu können natürlich
muss man das alles abgeben nichts davon
kannst du behalten du kannst auch nichts
verstecken du wirst am ganzen Körper
durchsucht
Blessing schuldet den Menschenhändlern
angeblich 35.000 Euro von den Freiern
erhält sie durchschnittlich 30 Euro
davon werden ihr diverse Nebenkosten
abgezogen
die übrigen 15 Euro dienen der
Schuldentilgung pro Tag muss Blessing
etwa drei bis fünf Freier bedienen sie
verdient also durchschnittlich 120 Euro
kann davon aber nur 60 Euro zur Tilgung
Einsetzen der Rest geht direkt an die
Menschenhändler so müsste Blessing etwa
2.300 mal mit fremden Männern bezahlten
Sex haben um ihre Schulden komplett zu
begleichen
Jan Philipp Scholz versucht über den Weg
des Geldes mehr über die Hintermänner zu
erfahren die blessing in die
Schuldenfalle lockten und bedrohten
in Frankfurt trifft er den Informanten
wieder er zeigt im Videomaterial von
einem mutmaßlichen Geldeintreiber
nein nein nein nein nein nimm das bloß
nicht auf die leichte Schulter
wir werden dich umbringen
er sagt wenn ich dich sehe werde ich
dich mit einer Pistole erschießen
er droht offenbar damit jemanden zu
töten
ja und er droht nicht nur der Person
selbst sondern der ganzen Familie
selber glaubt man vielleicht dass man
sich verstecken kann
die ganze Familie kann sich ja nicht
versteckend oder ja verdammt
beängstigend und das sind keine
Spielchen die meinen sowas Ernst
kannst du verstehen dass ich Opfer von
Menschenhandel davon einschüchtern
lassen
[Musik]
es gibt Leute in der Regierung Leute die
diese Sachen bekämpfen sollten die Angst
haben
Polizisten haben Angst vor denen das ist
kein Spiel das ist verdammt ernst
Jan Philipp Scholz verfolgt den Weg des
Geldes weiter bis nach Nigeria
er sucht eine Frau die auch in
lessingsfall verwickelt sein soll
am Flughafen trifft Scholz Solomon
okoduva dieser leitet eine Organisation
die sich um die Aufklärung von
menschenhandelsfällen kümmert die
Polizei ist hier selten eine Hilfe
ökodova hat bereits einen Zeugen
identifiziert ein Bruder von Blessing
dieser hat wahrscheinlich Informationen
die Scholz zu der Frau führen könnten
er hat Angst wir haben es schließlich
mit einer Art Kartell zu tun die Frau
wirkt auf den ersten Blick vielleicht
ganz sanftmütig diese madams sehen oft
überhaupt nicht furchteinflößend aus
aber sie haben ein mächtiges Netzwerk
hinter sich und manchmal reicht da ein
einziger Anruf
City ist eine der gefährlichsten Städte
Nigerias mehr als 80% der nigerianischen
Menschenhandels Opfer kommen aus dieser
Region
außerdem ist die Stadt eines der Zentren
von Nigerias Schattenwirtschaft richtig
für seine hawaage Agenten Hinterhof
Banker und Geldwäsche
Scholz trifft Lessings Bruder in einem
armen vor Ort der Stadt
dieser ist nervös
ung
wir alle in der Familie hatten keine
Ahnung dass meine Schwester nach Europa
wollte
später hat sie unser erzählt dass sie
eine Frau dabei geholfen hat sie hätte
vorher mit jemandem von uns darüber
sprechen sollen
sie 2019 weggegangen ist haben wir nur
Ärger hier diese Frau hat Schläger auf
uns angesetzt sie haben uns schon
mehrmals hier bedroht
erst letzte Woche wieder acht Männer
vorbei gekommen
sie wollten offenbar meinen Vater töten
Gott sei Dank war nicht zu Hause
ich habe alles aus einem Versteck
beobachtet
sie haben eine Notiz hinterlassen
wenn meine Schwester die Schulden bei
der Madame nicht abbezahlt werden sie
meinen Vater töten
seitdem kam schon wieder neue Drohungen
wir schlafen kaum noch irgendwann werden
sie bestimmt ernst machen
Salomon kann Festus überzeugen seine
Informationen mit ihm zu teilen und der
versucht bei der Polizei mehr über die
Angreifer herauszufinden
während sie warten erzählt er dass der
Menschenhandel in der Region immer
brutaler wird
die Folgen der Pandemie treiben viele
Nigerianer ins Ausland
und die Macht der Netzwerke sei
inzwischen so groß dass sie den
Zusammenhalt ganzer Familien zerstören
wo ist anders
wenn die Mutter eines Opfers von diesen
Gruppierungen ins Visier genommen wird
und solche massiven Drohungen ausgesetzt
ist sagt sie ihre Tochter in der Regel
mach was immer sie dir sagen wenn du
dich prostituieren musst dann
prostituiere dich hin
schau einfach dass du das Geld abbezahlt
bekommst und dass wir hier in Nigeria in
Frieden leben können
neue Informationen eine der
identifiziert Personen passt genau zu
der Beschreibung der Frau die Scholz
sucht
sie wurde laut Polizei bereits mehrfach
beschuldigt Menschenhandels Opfer zu
bedrohen und baut gerade in einem der
besten Stadtteile Berlin citys ein Haus
die Polizei entscheidet die Verdächtige
zu einem Verhör einzubestellen angeblich
hält sie sich gerade auf Ihrer Baustelle
auf
also die Frau wurde gesichtet deshalb
müssen wir sofort handeln
genau
lass uns hoffen dass die bald keinem
Opfer in Europa und keinen Familien mehr
das Leben zur Hölle machen kann
glaubst du das ist realistisch
hoffentlich ich hoffe schon
mit einer guten Zusammenarbeit der
Sicherheitsbehörden und mit Gottes Hilfe
werden wir Erfolg haben
die Verdächtige Baustelle hier entsteht
eine typische Vorstadtvilla vermutlich
finanziert durch die Ausbeutung von
Blessing und anderen Frauen vor dem Haus
eine höfliche gut gekleidete Dame
[Applaus]
sie lässt sich ohne Diskussionen mit
aufs Präsidium nehmen
nicht selten waren madams früher selbst
Prostituierte und haben sich im Lauf der
Jahre mit Intelligenz und
Skrupellosigkeit hochgearbeitet
wir werden jetzt umfangreiche
Ermittlungen anstellen dann werden wir
sehen inwieweit sie involviert ist
aber es gibt Hinweise
in diesem Fall und auch in zwei weiteren
Fällen wo Mädchen nach Dubai geschickt
wurden
das Haus wurde also wahrscheinlich mit
Geldern aus der Menschenhandel gebaut
optimistisch scheint die Ermittlerin
nicht zu sein
wenn wir feststellen dass es Beziehungen
zu Leuten in der Behörde gibt sehen wir
uns aus dem Fall zurück das kann
gefährlich werden das habe ich schon
selbst erlebt
sie haben vielleicht mächtige Freunde
dass es irgendwelche Verbindungen
zwischen Menschenhändlern und
staatlichen Stellen gibt wird uns das zu
heiß
eine Ermittlerin die offen erzählt das
Verfahren eingestellt werden wenn
Verdächtige gute Kontakte haben
das Geld aus der Zwangsprostitution
scheint diesen Ort zu einem quasi
Gesetzlosen Raum zu machen
[Musik]
am nächsten Tag erneut ein Treffen mit
Solomon auch er scheint trotz des
Erfolgs nicht zufrieden zu sein die
Verdächtige sei wahrscheinlich Teil
eines viel größeren Netzwerks und die
Bereitschaft der Behörden so schnell zu
handeln für Solomon hat sie auch mit der
Anwesenheit eines Fernsehteams zu tun
sie haben Verbindungsleute in allen
Sicherheitsbehörden diese Typen arbeiten
sogar direkt mit den madams zusammen
Opfer das mit dem Pass seiner anderen
Person nach Dubai gereist ist
so etwas ist nur möglich wenn hohe
Sicherheitsbeamte an den Flughafen
involviert sind internation
a ist überzeugt die Profiteure des
menschenhandelsitzen überall an den
Schalthebel der Macht
Scholz reißt weiter nach Laos der
Wirtschaftsmetropole Nigerias hier lebt
ein Großteil der Elite des Landes
sie stellt ihren Reichtum gerne zur
Schaum
während weit mehr als die Hälfte der
Nigerianer in absoluter Armut leben
investigativjournalist Nikola ibequee
beschäftigt sich seit Jahren mit den
Verbindungen zwischen der politischen
Elite und der organisierten Kriminalität
für ihn ist klar
nigeria hat sich durch die Macht der
kriminellen Netzwerke zu einer Art
mafia-stadt entwickelt
natürlich gibt es Korruption überall auf
der Welt aber der Unterschied zwischen
Nigeria und einem Land wie Schweden ist
dort werden Gesetze befolgt und es
entstehen keine Räume der Straflosigkeit
geben Sie die einfach einen Klaps auf
die Hand und lassen Dich laufen
hat dem schmutzigen Geld der
nigerianischen Elite mit
undercover-aktionen nachgespürt sein
Fazit oft führen die Spuren des Geldes
auf verstecktem Weg wieder zurück nach
Europa
so wie es aussieht ist London der
Lieblingsort dieser Elite aber sie
kaufen Eigentum in allen Ecken Europas
übernehmen die ganzen finanziellen
Abläufe für dich
sie helfen dir dabei Scheinfirmen zu
gründen und erledigen alles weitere
es geht immer um den politischen Willen
ich glaube die ganze internationale
Politik und Diplomatie ist vor allem
Heuchelei
die Spuren des schmutzigen Geldes führen
also ironischerweise dorthin zurück wo
sie begonnen haben nach Europa auch an
die Landstraße
zum großen Teil wird das Geld schon in
Nigeria investiert mit Handys aber neu
auch gesehen dass das Geld bereits in
der Schweiz und in Europa investiert
wird in Form von Immobilie in Form von
Discos vor
Produktionen im Bereich DJI diese
re-investments in der Schweiz hat die
Bundeskriminalpolizei in Bernburg aus im
visierer
der money von fatpol und Europa
sondern auch das Geld zu verfolgen und
die Werte einzuziehen die durch die
kriminellen Handlungen erwirtschaftet
werden
Kampf gegen die organisierte
Kriminalität
ansetzen für eine wirksame Bekämpfung
müsste man nach Meinung von Stefan Fuchs
aber auch dort wo man am ehesten zu
verwendbaren Zeugenaussagen für
Verfahren kommt
bei den betroffenen Frauen
bitte nigerianische Netzwerk kommt auf
jeden Fall denn wieder wenn man deine
Frau Sicherheit kapiert vom
finanziellenkt dass sie erkannt werden
Netzwerk und drittens auch ganz sicher
ein wichtiger Punkt dass sie in
Sicherheit kein russisch
das alles kann die Schweiz bisher nicht
garantieren darum ist es auch
verständlich dass die Frauen nicht
aussagen der Teufelskreis dreht sich
weiter
machen
die mutmaßliche menschenhändlerin in
Nigeria ist wieder freiem Fuß Blessing
hat neue Drohungen bekommen und einen
abschiebungsentscheid der
Ausländerbehörde trotzdem träumt sie
nach wie vor davon irgendwann in
Deutschland eine Chance zu bekommen
ich bin aus Nigeria weg weil ich ein
besseres Leben wollte wenn du in
Deutschland zur Schule gehst und dich
ein Regeln hältst kannst du die Person
werden die du gerne sein möchtest
du brauchst keine guten Beziehungen
und einen guten Job bekommen vielleicht
in einem Krankenhaus
wenn Frauen wie blessing in der Schweiz
legal arbeiten könnten wären sie nicht
mehr erpressbar sagt Cornelia Zöhrer
sie versteht nicht warum man hier
wegschaut
wer hat für Flüchtling
Opfer von Menschenhandel und Sie können
um an die Täter heranzukommen wäre aber
auch ein verstärkter Fokus der
internationalen Polizeiarbeit auf die
nigerianischen Netzwerke nötig
Interpol hat das vor kurzem angeregt und
die Schweizer Ermittlungsbehörden haben
den Handlungsbedarf offenbar ebenfalls
erkannt
wir kennen die Initiative von Interpol
und sind daran beteiligt wir haben unser
Interesse deutlich gemacht heute ist es
noch zu früh um darüber zu sprechen aber
wir sind effektiv Teil dieses Prozesses
das klingt gut doch Cornelia Zöhrer ist
nach all den Jahren an der Langstraße
der illusioniert jedes Mal wenn das
Problem in den letzten Jahren öffentlich
wurde hat sie bisher das gleiche erlebt
auf der anderen Druck es gibt Druck auf
Politik es gibt Druck auf die
Verantwortlichen
Zwangsprostitution und Menschenhandel
sind grausame Alltag für tausende Frauen
in Europa
und die Behörden können den
afrikanischen mafia-netzwerken bisher
noch keine wirklich wirksame Strategie
entgegensetzen ändern könnte sich das
Noah wenn die freie die das Geschäft
ankurbeln bereit wären auf die
Dienstleistungen dieser Prostituierten
zu verzichten
[Musik]